of any lemon pusher comment only
apparently well-established Newark
Dominion men have a collective complex
interests and women sever common cause
of interest class interest and these
interests are become accomplice there's
competition of collective level well I
think there is competition between men
and women but if nested inside a broader
arena cooperation you know this is
another thing that you learn from
reading Piaget if you're careful is but
confusion is smart enough to understand
that there is no dichotomous opposition
between cooperation and competition so
you know one of the sort of tenets of
the kind of leftist mumble jumble that I
hate is that you should kitchen play
competitive games right there's an equal
operative games but ok let's take that
apart let's take off this competitive or
cooperative
well competitive well wait a second no
one brings a basketball to the hockey
game right no one brings a chessboard
everyone that comes to the hockey game
comes there to play hockey that
constitutes cooperation will mutually
define that aim participation in
cooperation usually define the aim we'll
assign each other rules we'll all agree
to stick to the rules
well that's cooperation and then if you
break the rules what happens you stuck
in the penalty box you're gone playing
hockey off you go
and people people go off a cliff in the
penalty box
they don't go kill the referee with them
like the roller they going sit in the
penalty for you know six foot seven 300
pounds so okay and then you think well
what about within the team is that
cooperation of competition well each
team member is trying to be the best
player but it's try not passing to your
colleagues and see what happens you know
even if you're really good they'll just
you're just a diva and no one's going to
be happy with you know they'll put
horrible things in your beer after the
game
so it's cooperation there as well again
there's a meta level of cooperation
which is that everybody's trying to
improve their skills simultaneously and
so that that sure is a higher-order good
and everyone's trying to learn how to be
a good player so that they can play many
games by publishing three competitive
games like you must being educated at
noisy very fast and is it's so so
ignorant people who know something about
child development to say something like
that it's just what is with you where
were you educated or where were you
educated is the right response so and
then showing men and women well there is
group competition for example you're
competing roughly speaking with all your
classmates right and some of the women
are going to have shown you and so
that's that's tough for math which
particularly jumper men because it isn't
obvious how you compete full-bore with
women it's not obvious and we don't know
how to solve that problem